So, why do we get such a small number for this calculation? Well, if you think
way back to when we did exponent notation at the beginning of the course, we
talked about negative exponents and what they are. x to the negative 1 means 1
divided by x. x to the negative 2 means 1 over x squared. So if we multiply
something by x to the negative 1, we really want to divide that by x. And if we
multiply something by x to the negative 2, we really want to divide it by x
squared. So if we multiply something by 10 to the negative 4, what we really
want to do is divide it by 10 to the 4th. With multiplication by 10 to the
positive 4, the answer we got was bigger than the number we started with. But,
when we divide by 10th to the 4, it gets smaller. For each factor of 10 we're
dividing by, the decimal point moves one step to the left. So, we start with
3.1, then 1 factor of 10 makes it 0.31 and we keep moving it. As before, we end
up with these blank spots, we need to fill in zeros. Our decimal point is right
here now. So what we actually have is, as we saw before, 0.00031. Now, note
that I put a 0 in front of our decimal point, to the left of it. Now this is
the technically correct way to write decimal numbers in general. If you miss
out on writing this, it's kind of like using slang for everyday speech. People
will still know what you mean but its not quite as correct. Its not quite as
proper in mathematics. So now that we've seen one example of using a negative
exponent in scientific notation, I'm going to give you another one to try out.
Here is 3.1 times 10 to the negative 7. This time try without using a
calculator to write this in normal number notation.